hi i'm noah schnapp hi i'm steven singh
and i'm gate madarazzo and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
well let's get rid of this
oh you four bye for your
what tick-tock dance did noah schnapp
create create you create a dance well we
i actually made one last night we were
just like running behind everyone at the
party and just going like yeah you
encouraged me to do so as well yeah and
i didn't start is fun i was in bed
so oh my god it's 10 30. yeah he was
going hard what does noah snap do in his
free time i love like food i love eating
when i'm like
not doing anything i will be happy go to
college food yeah what is noah schnapps
favorite season of stranger things i
don't know what do you guys think i love
you're working too i think you are so
great i love like the halloweens yeah
that's always really really fun and
obviously
will storyline that was like sadie's
debut it wasn't this is his debut very
soon
what music video was noah schnapp i was
in a panic at the disco that was so sick
music video that was so cool
ten-year-old noah yeah that was awesome
i was like [ __ ] myself
you know all right
what does sadie sink
say in all too well i can't remember it
it's like there are a lot of people who
can there are people who know it by
heart like like you you drop my hand
yeah that's a big one what inspires
sadie sync crystals
no no i'd say more like um
cast members and stuff my cast members
inspire me actually
that like other actors
no but genuinely i don't know what else
would inspire cast members my dog my dog
inspired me every day
yeah what is sadie singh's favorite old
movie i mean the sound of music oh
that's me really yeah no way julie
andrews i think if i could like meet
anyone it might
have to be julian amazing what is sadie
sings fandom named let's make one if you
don't what's it gonna be
um
this is honestly fun but that's basic we
gotta come up with something oh yeah
sadists
that sounds
that's awesome
sure i don't know i'm sure
all right there you go
what is those bands
band
it's the cringiest story in the world
and it needs to be in like a really bad
like b band movie the band name was work
in progress we were trying to figure it
out because we were playing covers that
like open mics and then someone's like
was a real work in progress and they
were like that's it
and i can't regret my life ever since
what is next for gate madarasville
i don't know it's a bit of a work in
progress so
what is kate middleton thinking i was
just thinking about what's next what am
i thinking on your mind
that the star wars prequels are
underrated and i think people need to
revisit and just take their time know
that they're getting into a political
message i don't know it's just so
glamorous it is just so beautiful like
we were so used to like pirates and star
wars star wars yeah prequels the
prequels are so luxurious
zodiac sign so i'm a virgo i don't like
virgo as a sun so i'm gonna like claim
my moon which is libra i think libras
are what they're diplomatic they they
look at
all the sides of situations and both
sides of stories but it makes them
indecisive is what i keep reading you're
a libra libras are great what are you
i'm in i'm an aries what does that do
they're like
leaders and kind of yeah
supposedly aggressive but i think my
cancer rising cancels out the aggressive
fonts okay what is going on in stranger
things hawkins there's riffs to
alternate dimension crazy [ __ ] this girl
with superpowers you know kids on
bicycles kids on bikes man what is
stranger things aesthetic oh like
80s like fun music each season it
changes too kind of yeah that's true
like this season's aesthetic is very
different yeah it's a little gloomier i
think it's cool we kind of expand upon
the aesthetic of the first two seasons a
lot this year because like season three
aesthetically was kind of our black
sheep and now we go back to it and
expand upon what we what we did the
first two what stranger things fan
theories are right for season four i've
seen a lot of just way off a lot wrong
well because
i just noticed that like people were
really dissecting this one bit in the
trailer but it was just a production
error what was it it was like um
i love that so much
i i just don't know if i can say it
like netflix is watching
the um your mics
you're like whispering into them just
scratch this rep just rub the mic the
name on the tombstone
what are stranger things fans called
strangers weirdos
why do stranger things have a demogorgon
why doesn't it why would it be without a
democrat or any show that you're
watching why do stranger things make me
sad some sad [ __ ] happens oh my god
yeah i cried at the end of season three
yeah does sadie sing
does sadie sings character go to jail
no does sadie sink love millie bobby
brown yes we all love lily bobby brown
does sadie sing
last night sadie was going hard
wait what do they mean by gohan like
like like live it up like yeah go out of
the town you could just be like popping
off like at work it could be like
sadie's going hard right now
sadie is always going yeah thank you for
sure if they mean like staying up past
11
then no
does sadie sing play pokemon
no cute question
i don't i think it's one dude who's been
looking at it every day to the point
where it got into the
algorithm anyway i'm really really
curious um no i don't does sadie sing
have tattoos
no
you don't try to remember
i don't have anything like um
sentimental enough
yeah right so like
foreign tattoo i always forget about
yourself it's right over my ass is it
actually yeah no way with a smiley face
winking at you oh you're kidding yeah
i'm kidding i was like how do i get a
look at this it's like on his ass
okay why no schnapp why no schnapp going
to college i mean it's always been super
important for me i feel like i'm too
much of a kid and too young right now to
just go
live like in the real world just yet
what
noah schnapp emo white what's this isn't
noah schnapp emo why aren't you emo why
isn't no um i'll think about it i'll
i'll think about going emo do you think
you have any emo attendancy like what is
an emo attendance well i think we've all
got a couple no season two games two
games yeah
we don't but we don't we're not going to
talk about this don't talk about bruno
that was just going to say that where
you were i was like singing in my head i
was like i feel like um
why is
why am i not zendaya i mean
i'm just i'm noah unfortunately
unfortunately i wish i was why am i not
sending it why not why aren't you why
isn't he said
why isn't noah schnapp that way what are
these questions about
who's googling him
that way i'm like kind of offended it
could be a compliment it could be like
that
yeah
who is gayton madarazzo off camera uh
douche who it is gate and matarazzo
remind me of i mean some guy on the
street would stop me i assumed he was a
fan of the show and he goes hey man you
look
just like elijah would you thought he
was going to like play up a bit or
something so maybe maybe maybe
who does gate madarazzo want to act with
that's a fun question i'm a big fan of
noah schnapp i'm a big fan of sadie
saying i love both their work i mean who
would you want to act with most out of
like the whole cat out of the whole cat
someone you haven't worked with before
matt duffer oh my god
let's see
who is getting madarazzo on broadway
i was in les mis i was gavroche and les
mis it would have been weird if i played
anybody else because i was 11. it was
really good i saw the [ __ ] what you saw
me in les miserables it's been seven
years why are we just now talking about
this i mean i didn't like we didn't know
each other well yeah i was in the
audience that's awesome yeah you're
really good thanks bud what do y'all
think of the question there were a
couple great ones and there were a
couple it was amazing the pokemon the
pokemon
i think i probably googled dumber stuff
[Music]